قد تكون أكوام القمامة في شوارع باريس
واحدة من أكثر المشاكل فوضى
الناجمة عن الإضرابات الوطنية في فرنسا
احتجاجًا على خطة الحكومة لرفع
سن التقاعد للعمال إلى 64 عامًا.
ويقول مكتب عمدة باريس إن أكثر من
4000 طن من القمامة قد تم جمعها  في انتظار أن يتم
جمعها في جميع أنحاء المدينة ولكن حتى الآن
لم يتم نقل القمامة إلى أي مكان لأن العديد من
جامعي القمامة تركوا وظائفهم يوم
الثلاثاء الماضي جنبًا إلى جنب مع عمال المرافق
والمدرسين لتدريب السائقين وغيرهم
لإظهار غضبهم من
الإصلاحات المقترحة، كما قام العمال أيضًا بإغلاق
محارق القمامة  بالقرب من المدينة
ويقول السكان إن ما تبقى في الشوارع
بدأ بالرائحة الكريهة أه
هذا هناك
جرذان وفئران لقد
رأيتهم لذا إنه لأمر فظيع إنه
منظر غير شهي خارج
المحلات التجارية والمقاهي الشهيرة في المدينة والمتاجر الفاخرة
المحاطة بصناديق القمامة بالقرب
امتلأت المطاعم المحلية بالأكياس البلاستيكية السوداء
وصناديق الطعام، ويطلب بعض المسؤولين
استخدام المزيد من المقاولين من القطاع الخاص
لالتقاط القمامة لأن الحشد أصبح
يمثل خطرا على الصحة بالنسبة للزعيم النقابي
خارج محرقة كبيرة في المدينة،
ويقول إن الحصار سيظل ساريا
حتى يوم الثلاثاء على الأقل